- We are here with Ben
Affleck, Matt Damon,
and Chris Tucker, y'all,
give it up!
(audience applauds)
Together they star in "Air."
It's in theater starting April 5th.
It's such an excellent film.
So Matt and Ben,
did you meet Michael
Jordan before doing this?
Did you feel like-
- Chris knows him.
- Of course you know him!
- I know Michael.
(audience laughs)
I know Michael.
- Oh my god!
- You really do know him? (laughs)
- Yeah, Michael, I met him years ago.
I used to take my son to Santa Barbara
to his camp he did for kids every year.
And I really was going
to see Michael myself,
but I used my kid,
(Kelly laughs)
just to get in there and
get my autograph first.
So I said, "Oh, here's my son.
"You can do his autograph too!"
But I remember
(Kelly laughs)
one time he rode in my car
and I'll never forget that,
because we were all going out to dinner
after the camp and all that stuff.
And I couldn't believe he was in my car.
"Dude, this your car?"
It was a new Bentley.
"It's a brand new Bentley?
"This is nice."
I was looking at him like,
"I'm never gonna sell this car."
(audience laughs)
"Michael Jordan is in my car!"
- And also like, "Don't crash." (laughs)
- (laughs) Yeah, like,
"Don't hurt his knees!
"Everybody'll kill me."
So, oh man, doing this
movie is just a treat.
- I've heard he's super
competitive, though,
so did you ever play him or anything?
- Oh, never played.
He won't play me in anything.
Some night I was down
at his golf course-
- Are you afraid to play him?
- And his friends was like,
"Would you play Chris?"
He said, "No, no, no!"
Because he loved to tease you.
I went to his party one
time, the All-Star Weekend.
He was like, "What you doing in here?
"How you get in here, what?"
(audience laughs)
"I've been invited!"
"No, you weren't, you weren't invited."
(audience laughs)
- He's funny, that's funny.
- I said, "Ain't stuntin you."
(Ben laughs)
- That's incredible.
Okay, speaking of competitive,
is it true that you are in a,
this is just interesting
to me, cuz I'm a wordsmith.
I love words.
You're in a "Wordle" group
with Chris's "Silver Linings"
co-star Bradley Cooper.
Is this true?
- No, I'm trying to get into it.
Oh, you're not-
- And I'm being velvet roped
by the bouncer here.
He's telling me that I
gotta get cooler plus-one
- I don't know-
- It's not easy.
- We play, so there's "Octordle,"
which is the eight words.
And then "Quordle,"
which is the four words,
and then Wordle, which is the one.
So we play all three and
you add up your score.
- All right, "Will Hunting,"
just get to the point.
(Chris, Matt, and Kelly laugh)
(audience laughs)
- No, it's very, very competitive.
Will Arnette is in it, Bradley Cooper,
Jason Bateman.
- And I'm not, which is fine.
I don't resent.
(audience laughs)
- No, I advised you,
you're welcome to join.
I just advised you, we call
it the Nerdle League. (laughs)
I was like, "You can
join the Nerdle League,
"but you might want to
get your scores down."
- The truth is, they told
me what their scores were.
I was like, "I can get in."
Then I did it a couple times.
I was like, "I might need to train."
(audience laughs)
- That's hard for me.
I love words and stuff, but it's hard.
Especially with the five,
I'm always like, "What?"
And I have friends that
are brilliant at it.
I wouldn't be invited either.
I do love that y'all play that though.
So what's the last "Wordle"
word that was controversial
for you guys?
What's the last one you were like, "No."
- I'm not a fan of "Quordle,"
which is the four words.
The people are a little sinister,
because they'll do words like rarer
and I'm like, "You're gonna
do three Rs in one word?
"You guys suck."
(Kelly laughs)
(laughs) You know what I mean?
'Cause it's whenever you flame out,
when you don't get, you blow out.
We call it a blowout,
and I'm just like, "I
blow out on Quordle."
And it's always "Quordle" that gets me,
and I'm always angry
when I look at the word
and I'm like, you know,
and it's like pappy or something-
- I was doing it
with my mom the other day-
- Three Ps.
- she really objected to sooth.
Sooth was the word.
- Sooth, yeah.
- I said, "No, it's
truth, it's like forsooth.
And she said, "Well, that's archaic.
"That's not fair."
She really-
- This is my mother
playing Scrabble, she will
yell at me and my sister
and she'll be like,
"Qi, really, Q I?
"Okay, we're going with it, okay, cool."
- If you play Scrabble,
you're all about the qi.
- Believe me, all the Q I, or, believe me,
(indistinct)-
- Q A T.
- If you don't have a U,
you are screwed.
- K A V A.
- No, I love words-
- Or 'za,
that's the worst, for pizza, 'za.
- I'm telling my, my sister-
- No, no, I don't buy that.
- Oh my God, I hope my sister-
- It's not
in the Scrabble dictionary.
- She used 'za
when we were in New York first Christmas
and my mom lost her (beep).
(Matt laughs)
She was like, "That's not a word."
And she's a teacher,
so it was very hard to swallow.
- The whether-or-not-a-thing-is-a-word
dispute
has caused some serious fractions.
- Because then you look it
up and everything's a word.
- Everything's a word
if you go to the Scrabble
dictionary on your phone.
- You can't just use
the "Urban Dictionary"
cuz everything's slang-
- No, no,
even in the regular one.
- for something.
- "How does this mean 50,"
can't even mention-
- My mom will get
- What it is.
- So upset about it.
It's so funny.
"'Za okay, we're going with 'za."
- 'Za, then okay, does
anything, any expression,
(Kelly laughs)
getting into my arguments now.
- I love the way this interview went.
(all laugh)
I know my mom and sister
are gonna be like, "What?
"You had these people here
and you talked about what?"
What's your greatest, did
y'all play sports growing up?
What's your greatest
achievement with sports?
I played sport.
I liked playing sports.
I was not-
- I got cut from the B team,
(Kelly laughs)
like Michael Jordan.
I got cut,
but then I started hosting talent shows
and found my true passion.
- Your calling?
- Stand-up comedy and acting.
So it was meant to be.
- I liked playing, I wasn't great.
I was just good.
- I lettered in theater.
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
That's true.
- You sexy thing, you.
- I know, I lettered in theater, but-
- I did too, but I don't tell people.
(Matt laughs)
I hit a ground rule double
when I was 12 years old to tie
the game in the championship.
I mean the local championship.
- I actually don't know what that is.
What is that?
- Ground rule double is-
- It's not a home run,
but it bounces once
and then goes over the fence.
(audience laughs)
- So you get second base.
- It's the closest I came
to a home run, the left center field.
I will never forget it as long as I live.
When you're a kid, it's-
- I love those moments, yeah.
- It was incredible.
- I got to take batting
practice in Fenway Park,
and I hit the Green Monster
off of a pitch that my father threw me.
So that was like-
(audience applauds)
- Do you know what's Interesting?
I have played where the scorer is,
I've been in the Green Monster
and played catch with my brother.
- Oh, really?
- We were like,
"We just gotta do it
"'cause we just gotta say we've done it."
- Yeah, absolutely,
- Fenway's fun.
- It was so cool.
- The tours are great.
- He was all over there,
'cause in the town they, how
long did you shoot there?
- We had three weeks to shoot a robbery,
and it was amazing.
It's got this labyrinthian,
it's old but they fixed it up,
so there's all these
secret tunnels and stuff
and it's one of the few last,
or the old parks around.
That was 1908 or 1912, whenever was built.
And it's a beautiful park.
If you're ever in Boston, I have to say,
check it out, it's a lot of fun.
- I agree, I love Boston.
My first time to experience
sports outside of Texas,
cuz I'm Texan,
and we are very passionate people,
(Matt laughs)
so are Bostonians.
So I went to a game,
I sang at a World Series and I was like,
"I love these people!"
Everybody was losing their mind.
it's very close
to that's mentality.
- That's what's going on
in Boston.
- I know, but it's fun!
- It's basically what-
- Why be there unless you're
gonna have a good time?
See, that's my point.
(audience applauds)
We have to talk about the actual shoe,
the shoes are amazing.
I've been a fan since I was a kid.
Do you remember the first pair of sneakers
that you bought that made you feel cool?
'Cause I grew up with no money
so most of my poor sneakers
had marks on the floor.
But the first pair I bought,
I just felt like, it was
with my first check, too.
- That you bought on your own?
- And I bought,
from my job I bought, and
I felt, I wore them out.
- I had the Jordan 4s.
I bought the Jordan 4s.
I was about 11th grade, '89,
and I had to save money working
for my daddy's company,
Tucker Cleaning Service.
'Cause people have been asking me,
and I had to go back and find,
"What was that shoe?"
It was the Jordan 4s.
But it's the energy man.
Clothes make you feel good.
The Jordans make you feel
like you can jump like
Jordan and all that.
And that's what this movie got in.
People buy shoes
and buy clothes because
it makes 'em feel good.
It's good for your mental state.
- I'm glad you just said that,
because that was the most
interesting thing too
that I found, there were
a lot of interesting,
I'm gonna say that about everything,
but I had no idea
that the league only allowed you
to wear a certain type of
shoe for a certain time.
And then it was like
you had to pay a fine.
I didn't know that either.
- It had to be a 51% white.
- [Kelly] I know!
- They did not allow
the shoe to have color.
- I had no idea of that.
All this information that's in there,
and then that shoe is revealed
and you're just like, "It is so magic."
This film is so good.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)
It's so good.
- Thank you.
- I loved it.
I thought it was so cool.
So one of the main themes
of the movie is fighting
for your own self worth.
When do you feel
like you've had to fight
for that in your life?
- I think the act of being an actor.
(all laugh)
It's like a lifelong-
- Every time I come on this lot,
I just remember holding my sides
in some audition and, "No,
"you don't need to do the second scene.
"We've seen all we need."
- "Good, thanks."
- There's a lot of that soul.
It beats you down, it-
- I love that you talk about that though,
because young actors,
the younger actors are probably like,
they feel defeated and they see
y'all and they're like, "Aw,
"they made a movie and made it,
"and everything was so magical."
And they don't see everything-
- Listen we had to be
- That happened before.
- Incredibly lucky very young,
and still there were probably
500 parts we didn't get, easily.
- So many rejections.
It's a helpful thing
about having your best friend do it too,
because we used to call
it getting okay thanks'ed.
You'd go into a room and
you'd pour your heart out
for a casting director and a director
and they'd go like, "Okay, thanks."
And you'd realize, "I
didn't get the part."
Meanwhile you've been sitting out there
for 45 minutes waiting as
the last person was in there
and they come out and they're all laughing
and hugging and, "Oh, see you later."
And you're like, "Oh,
well, that went well."
And then you're out in five minutes
and you're like,
and all you really have is we'd go home.
We lived together with his little brother,
and we'd just go sit
there and, "How'd it go?"
"I got okay, thanks'ed," and
"Ah, it's all right, man,
"the hell with that."
You know what I mean,
they don't know what they,
and you kind of-
- It's a job interview
where you're also pouring your heart out
and crying too.
"Why won't you?"
"Thanks, that's fine."
"Are we good?
"Okay, 'cause I'm sobbing."
I'm remembering the most traumatic moment
in my life and I can go home.
- But cool, "Okay, thanks." (laughs)
What do you feel like for you,
what do you feel like was a moment
for you when you were younger?
- Oh man, I would say, stand-up comedy,
going on stages,
making sure that you're ready
and you have audience.
Sometimes you have great shows,
sometimes you have lukewarm shows,
so you gotta go back
to the clubs-
- Did you ever really struggle
or were you just like
pop bang right outta-
- Yeah, I didn't really
struggle that much.
(Matt and Ben laugh)
(audience laughs)
I was trying to find something.
- Oh my God, you're like in
here with binoculars searching.
(Chris laughs)
- Well that's a blessing that we had.
I had standup to fall on,
cuz when it's no work in Hollywood,
we was on the road every weekend
and we got that audience response,
so it kept you up, kept you going.
- It is interesting too,
because the audience plays such a big role
and I don't know that
everybody knows that.
But I think we realized in Covid,
and everybody's doing
drive-in theater shows
and stuff like that where you don't
really get that interaction.
But that live, or if
you've done live theater,
that live interaction,
you get drunk off that energy.
- And that's like-
- Even sitting in the room with a movie,
which as a director is the only time
you get that-
- You feel it differently.
- This movie in particular,
because it's funny
and it's optimistic and
the acting's so good.
You just like it more with other
people around you laughing.
- I agree too, 'cause I
watched it with friends
and I was like,
just having that you're
almost looking at each other
like you're rooting for people to win,
and you're rooting for them
to believe in them, and, yeah.
Well, we're almost out of time,
but I have to ask,
did you ever get distracted
by Ben's hair in the movie?
(Matt and Chris laugh)
'Cause I feel like it should
have gotten, it's ability-
- It I did, but it helped me.
It helped me in seeing where we were in.
I was like, "Man,
"this is something right here!"
- Is that a real perm?
- If I look crazy,
everyone else will know
they're gonna look better by comparison.
- The windsuit with the
glasses and the perm?
- That was historically documented.
I did not put on one piece of clothing
that I did not see was worn by-
- [Kelly] But don't tell me
you weren't excited. (laughs)
- I loved it
I still wear the stuff at home.
- Everybody could hear you
coming. (imitates whooshing)
- He's so good in this movie
= And a big shout out to Charlese,
our costume designer-
- Did an amazing job.
- Who crushed it.
This is all stuff,
when Sunny, the real Sunny came to the set
with his wife
and they looked at me
and Charlene was standing there
and they turned to her
and and his wife said,
"Did you raid his closet?"
I was wearing all this stuff,
and she had just kind of intuited exactly
what he would wear.
- In fact, I think
we have a gift for you.
- It's important to-
- I brought you something.
Somebody's gonna materialize.
There we go.
Look at this.
I thought that this is-
- The only thing is,
you have to wear them.
- Ooh, fun!
(audience applauds)
You bet your ass. (laughs)
(Matt laughs)
I wish I was skiing right now. (laughs)
This is incredible.
- Let's go!
You're welcome, America.
(audience cheers)
You're welcome, just a
little of this action, like
"Ferris Bueller's Day Off."
- Did you just say,
"You're welcome, America"?
- "You're welcome, America."
- That's so good.
- I know you wanna make-
- Come for a minute
with Daft Punk, we
thought it would be like-
- They're super cool,
I'm gonna actually go out with it, fun.
One more time,
for Ben Affleck, Matt
Damon, and Chris Tucker.
(audience applauds)
"Air" Is in theaters
everywhere starting Friday,
and look for it coming
soon on Prime Video.